hey guys this is vadim with max tech and
welcome to my gaming review
of the 2020 5k imac
as you guys can see we have windows 10
running using bootcamp right here
and let me give you guys the specs
before we begin this is the 10 core
model with the top of the line
5700 xd graphics card with 16 gigs of
vram and this model is packed with 64
gigs of ram that we bought off amazon
for only 250 bucks instead of paying
apple a ridiculous
thousand dollars for their ram so
definitely do that yourself and
install it by yourself using our ram
guide now what i'm gonna do in this
video is run a couple of gaming
benchmarks and then play some fortnite
and some call of duty warzone to see
just how much
fps we can get on this new imac
now the most important thing you need to
know if you're gonna buy this imac and
play windows games
using bootcamp is do not stick with
the regular 512 gig ssd
that's what i have right here and i
struggled to fit these games i barely
had enough storage so
get at least one terabyte or two
terabytes just to be safe
all right so i have units in heaven
right here i don't know why this window
is so tiny but we're gonna run the
extreme
preset the reason we do this is so we
can cross reference this between other
macs
like the 5600m macbook pro that we just
tested so
let's go ahead and run this on mac os
this actually got a really
really impressive score i think around
96 fps
which makes it the fastest graphics card
other than
the mac pro wow this score is insane
guys check this out 104.8
fps with the 5700 xt
that is almost 10 fps more than we got
on mac os and comparing it to the 5600 m
16 macbook pro that's over 20
fps more than that macbook pro which is
more expensive
than this 2020 imac and now it's time to
run
the popular 3dmark time spy benchmark
this is actually the same one we ran on
the 16-inch macbook pro with the 5600m
so let's go ahead
alright so we just got the score 7 465
points
the 16-inch macbook pro actually got
55.73
with the 5600m so wow that macbook pro
is impressive because this is not that
much higher around 34
faster than that highest end macbook pro
which is actually more expensive
and with that let's go ahead and jump
into fortnite right here
all right here we are in the settings
and i did the automatic
suggested settings and it put us into
5k resolution which is native and it
automatically set
everything to epic which is just insane
for some reason i just tried to do full
screen and it was just kind of messing
up
so i guess i'm just gonna stick with
windowed full screen
alright so as expected epic on all the
settings with 5k
resolution it's at around 20 fps
definitely not optimal this is
unplayable 25 fps right now let's go
high with a hundred percent
3d resolution make sure we still have
that 5k on there between
25 and 33 fps is what i'm getting so far
what's this guy doing you're going to
run me over
oh someone's shooting at me dude get out
of here
oh i'm so bad uh blame it on the fps
it on the fps alright so now i'm
switching it to full screen
1440p epic settings 100 3d res
there you go that's better running 1440p
epic maxed out everything getting about
90 fps right now
that's pretty good for 1440p all right
so far we're sticking to around 75
80 fps 73 right now
and yeah what's up dude i think that was
a bot
guys don't grill me on playing against
bots because i don't play this game
as i was saying i have not seen it dip
below 60
at all even when there's some kind of
spike or frame drop
that's pretty impressive epic everything
maxed out 100 resolution
and 1440p right now and it's working
great and because of the processor
really good tension processor
everything's
very very smooth right now look at that
90 fps 91 92 fps
yeah that's a bot
look this is is this the matrix dude i
can't hit this dude what is this
guys don't let me on your team man
got him all right i'm gonna go ahead and
turn on
1080p keep everything else on epic as it
was just to show you guys how much fps
you can get if you're playing at 1080p
or if you want to hook up an external
monitor
120 fps so technically
you can hook up a gaming monitor
hertz and play with high refresh rate
and just to get it a little bit higher
i'm going to set it down to high
keep the 3d res the same apply and there
you guys go
180 fps so if you really want to play
at high refresh rate there you guys go
1080p
and just because i'm curious i'm gonna
go back go back up to 1440p
and actually set it to medium with 100
3d res
what do we get oh snap dude get out of
here bro oh you kidding me
all right so i was interrupted by that
guy on the helicopter but
so as you guys saw i set it to 1440p
resolution
set the settings to medium and right now
we're still getting about 180 fps
let's see what fps we get when we land
we've landed
and we're sticking to around 160 fps
i haven't seen it below 147 i think so
there you go 144 hertz monitor gaming
monitor
and you're playing at 1440p and by the
way can you guys hear those fans
they're honestly not that loud it's like
a quiet
whisper and it hasn't been bugging me at
all playing fortnite and now let's
finally get
into some call of duty war zone all
right guys here we are in the settings
i've set it to full screen
got the card right there the screen
refresh rate
60 you can't really change that but i've
turned off the frame rate limit
the display resolution is at 5k but it's
set to 50
so it's at 1440p resolution textures on
high
low low particle quality these two
disabled
normal shadow map resolution these two
disabled particle lighting on low
this other stuff disabled anti-aliasing
disabled
all right guys here we are in game so
far look at that 104 fps 100 fps
124 fps here indoors and i do hear the
fans right now
they're kicking up but not that bad
and whoa bro you're hiding
come on man 120 130 fps on the gulag so
you're over here right bro so i'm
queuing up
for some more solo but i'm going to turn
the settings down just a slight bit
i'm going to go down to normal on that
and shadow map resolution
just going to go down to low all right
so it looks like doing that
just lowering it a little bit didn't
really do anything at all
we're still sitting at around 100 so not
quite
144 let me see if i can go down just a
little bit
go down to low does it do anything
120 honestly didn't really do much
so that's still pretty impressive but i
do want to mention that
i just installed boot camp i didn't
change any drivers at all these are the
factory drivers
over time the fps is gonna improve as
better drivers come out for this card
come on so it looks like at 1440p
resolution you can't
quite get 144 fps if you're trying to
use
an external gaming monitor at 60 you're
gonna be totally fine but let's go ahead
and try
1080p let's turn on every single setting
yeah look at that 144 fps that we're
getting right now
when we go outside it does go down a
little bit though but hey it's feeling
pretty smooth so i'm pretty impressed
151 we just hit
gotti all right just because i'm curious
we saw how much fps we can get if we're
trying to connect
an external display like 120 144 hertz
display
but let's see how much fps we can get if
we're gonna keep the 60 hertz
imac display so let's turn this up i'm
gonna go to
4k wow look at that guys 4k
high settings 77 fps right there 74.
wow i wasn't expecting that 80 fps oh
snap
i might even try out 5k 5k
resolution i'm actually going to turn
these settings down to low
all right so it looks like getting
around 47
46 fps at 5k
and right now it actually just hit 60
while i'm under here
wow everything looks insane right now
dude come on bro what you doing alright
guys so after running
all of those games and benchmarks let's
finish off with what i learned
well first of all definitely get at
least one terabyte of ssd
and based on what i'm seeing here
fortnite was performing better than call
of duty so maybe there's some
optimization issues with call of duty of
course i'm using the automatic
drivers i didn't update any drivers so
performance should be improving over
time now this
is the 10 core model with the 5700 xt
and 64 gigs of ram
now i would personally recommend to go
with the 8 core i7
that's definitely a better bang for the
buck for gaming and you really only need
about 32 gigs of ram you don't really
need 64
but you could get more if you want to
now this imac has
the top of the line 5700 xd graphics
card
for 500 more now the main benefit of
that
is the 16 gigs of vram which is helpful
for video editing 3d rendering and
hooking up external
displays now if you're not sure about
spending five hundred dollars
and you're wondering about the 5700 for
three hundred dollars more
one of our viewers actually ran the
union heaven extreme preset and he got
89.8 fps in mac os
so the xt version actually gets around 8
more fps in that test that's a 200
upgrade for
8 more fps now based on the results of
this video
i can surely say that if you want to
play games using bootcamp
on a mac that the 2020 5k imac is the
best
bang for the buck mac you can get for
gaming so hopefully you guys enjoyed
this video we're going to be doing a lot
more
testing with this imac we're going to do
a full comparison to
that 16-inch macbook pro with the 5600m
and we're going to compare it to the
other imacs as well the imac pro
the mac pro so definitely subscribe by
clicking that circle above right now so
you don't miss out on those videos
and be sure to check out our apple
product merch down below
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]